>> Greg: WELCOME BACK.
IT'S TIME FOR GREG'S HYPOCRITE
OF THE WEEK.
THIS IS A NEW SEGMENT WHERE I
THINK A LOT OF PERSON WHO SAYS
ONE THING THEN DOES ANOTHER.
THIS WEEK'S HYPOCRITE...
HYPOCRITE NUMBER ONE IS
GREG GUTFELD.
WHY?
BECAUSE ON THE SHOW I SLAMMED
THE USE OF SECRET RECORDINGS AND
VIDEOS WERE INVESTIGATORS GET
STAFFERS TO NARC ON THEIR BOSSES
AT BARS.
IF YOU RECORD PEOPLE LONG ENOUGH
WHILE THEY ARE DRINKING, YOU CAN
GET THEM TO SAY ANYTHING.
THAT SCARES ME EXCEPT WHEN IT
COMES TO CNN.
PROJECT VERITAS RELEASE
RECORDINGS OF CNN NEWS CALL
BETWEEN STAFFERS AND JEFF SACHAR
WHERE HE VALIDATES YOUR
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT THE GOAL OF
HIS NETWORK.
TO BE THE TRUMP IMPEACHMENT
NETWORK.
IN ORDER TO GET EYEBALLS IN
REVENGE WHILE STILL CALLING IT
NEWS.
>> MOVING TOWARDS IMPEACHMENT.
WE SHOULDN'T PRETEND THIS IS
GOING ONE WAY AND SO ALL OF
THESE MOVES ARE MOVES TOWARDS
IMPEACHMENT.
SO DON'T LOSE SIGHT OF IT.
>> Greg: EARTH SHATTERING.
DO I FEEL GOOD DISCUSSING THIS
SNEAKY STUFF?
NO.
BUT I DO FEEL GOOD THAT WE ARE
HEARING FROM THE HORSE'S MOUTH
EXACTLY WHAT WE KNEW ALL ALONG,
THAT AFTER DOING THEIR BEST TO
MAKE TRUMP THE NOMINEE, FIGURING
HE WOULD LOSE, CNN MUST NOW
DESTROY TRUMP BECAUSE HE WON.
IT'S NOT NEWS TO YOU.
WE KNEW THIS.
NOW IT CAN BE NO LONGER DENIED
BY CNN WHICH IS NICE GIVING ALL
THE TIMES THEY HAVE ACCUSED
TRUMP SUPPORTERS BEING DUMB
SHEEP.
LIKE THIS FROM LAST NIGHT.
>> IF ENOUGH AMERICANS,
REMEMBER, TRUMP HAS 30, 31%.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE FACTS,
THEY DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE FACTS.
THEY ARE FINE PEOPLE EXCEPT THEY
ARE IGNORANT ABOUT THESE THINGS
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT AND
THEY WILL NOT BUDGE.
>> Greg: DOES THAT SNAP ON AND
SNAP OFF?
WAS THAT COMMENTARY OR NEWS?
WHO CARES.
IT IS ALL THE SAME TO THEM.
IT'S MADE TO ORDER FOR THEIR
BOSS.
AS MUCH AS I HATE SECRET
RECORDINGS, I WILL TAKE THIS ONE
AND BY THE WAY SO SHOULD CNN.
THEY DO LOVE A GOOD
WHISTLE-BLOWER, DON'T THEY?
ALL RIGHT.
JESSE.
>> Jesse: YES.
>> Greg: HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
THIS?
>> Jesse: THE HAIR?
I LOVE IT.
I WISH I HAD HAIR LIKE THAT.
I NEED TO COMB AND OVER MORE TO
THE FRONT.
IT'S A HELMET AND LOOKS GOOD ON
HIM BUT I DON'T BELIEVE ANYTHING
ELSE HE SAID.
>> Greg: WHAT IS THE PLUS OR
MINUS THE VIDEO?
>> Jesse: ARE NOT BLOWN AWAY
BY THE CONTENT.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT OF CNN
SAYING WE HAVE TO FOLLOW
IMPEACHMENT HEART IS NOT
BREAKING NEWS.
OR THAT HE SAID LET'S TELL
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
OR THAT HE SAID FOX NEWS IS
DISRUPTIVE.
HE SAID IT OUT IN THE OPEN MANY
TIMES.
THE PEOPLE THEY DID GET ACCESS
TO SEEM TO ME TO BE LOW-LEVEL
PLAYERS WITHOUT EDITORIAL POWER.
HE MENTIONED THAT ZUCKER FEELS
GUILTY ABOUT "THE APPRENTICE"
AND IS TRYING TO GET REVENGE.
THAT'S NOT BREAKING NEWS.
CNN SAYS IT'S A NONBIASED
STRAIGHT NEWS ORGANIZATION EVEN
IN PRIME TIME WHEN THEY ARE
CLEARLY NOT.
IT'S NOT -- HE'S NOT A
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
I THINK YOU WILL NEVER GET HIRED
AGAIN.
THIS IS ONE OR TWO VIDEOS,
EXPECTING A THIRD, ANTICIPATING
SOMETHING MORE.
I'M EXCITED.
GREAT JOURNALIST AND A BRAVE GUY
LOOKING FOR TRUTH.
AT THIS POINT I'M STILL WAITING
FOR A BIGGER MORE EXPLOSIVE
THINGS.
>> Greg: DANA, THAT WAS VERY
FAIR AND BALANCED FROM JESSE.
HE SAID HE LIKED THE WORK BUT
WAS DISAPPOINTED IN THE PRODUCT.
I THINK WHAT GETS ME, BRIAN
STELTER IS WRITING A BOOK ABOUT
FOX NEWS.
HE WORKS AT CNN AND HE'S WRITING
A BOOK AND THEY ARE CONSTANTLY
CALLING US STATE RUN.
>> Dana: WHAT WOULD THEY TALK
ABOUT WITHOUT FOX NEWS?
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> Dana: NOT JUST CNN.
>> Greg: THEY ARE RUN WITH AN
IDEOLOGY.
>> Dana: HERE'S THE THING, I
DON'T LIKE SEEKER VIDEOS.
I THINK PEOPLE -- JUST BEFORE I
KNOW.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
>> Dana: [LAUGHS]
THAT WAS TERRIBLE.
>> Jesse: YOU ACID WASHED THAT
ONE, GUTFELD.
>> Dana: IF YOU ARE COMPETING
IN TERMS OF IDEOLOGY OR A
CORPORATION OR TEAM, WIN ON THE
MERITS.
IF THERE WAS US PORTS ORIENTED
MEETING AND HE WENT INTO A
TEAM LOCKER ROOM AND GAVE
INFORMATION TO THE EAGLES.
I WAS GOING TO SAY THE SILLIEST
PEOPLE ARE LIKE THAT'S WHAT THEY
WERE GOING TO DO.
PEOPLE WOULD BE OUTRAGE.
THE COWBOYS AND THE EAGLES
CONFIDE OUT AND SEE WHO WINS.
IT WILL PROBABLY BE THE COWBOYS.
>> Jesse: THE EAGLES.
COME ON!
>> Greg: JUAN, I'M GOING TO
FLOAT A THEORY.
DURING THE ELECTION, FNC WASN'T
TRUMP TV.
WE HAD 19 CANDIDATES.
WE WERE HAVING INTENSE FIGHTS.
I WASN'T FOR TRUMP.
I WAS A MARCO RUBIO GUY.
WE WERE FIGHTING ABOUT.
CNN, NONE OF THOSE AS OTHER
CANDIDATES MATTERED.
THEY PUT ALL OF THEIR EGGS ON
TRUMP.
I THINK NOW THEY FEEL GUILTY
ABOUT IT.
CALLING US STATE RUN IS
HILARIOUS BUT THEY WERE -- THIS
IS THEIR PENANCE.
>> Juan: YOU WRITE ABOUT THE
ZUCKER-TRUMP RELATIONSHIP.
WE ALL GAVE A LOT OF AIRTIME TO
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Greg: I THINK WE WERE THE
FAIREST NETWORK OF ALL.
"THE FIVE," WE WERE RIPPING EACH
OTHERS THROATS OUT.
>> Juan: I'M SAYING FORGET
WHAT WE SAY.
IT WAS THE COVERAGE OF THE TRUMP
RALLIES.
I DIDN'T THINK TRUMP DID THAT
WELL IN THE DEBATES BUT THE
RALLIES IS WHAT WAS GREAT TV AND
EVERYBODY COVERED IT AS TV
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING IT HAS
POLITICAL CONSEQUENCE.
TO MY MIND, I HAVE WORKED FOR
SEVERAL JOURNALIST ORGANIZATION
ORGANIZATIONS.
IF YOU WIRETAPPED ANY OF OUR
MORNING EDITORIAL CALLS, YOU
WOULD HEAR STUFF AND SAY IS THAT
BIASED?
IS IT NOT BIASED?
THERE'S NO BIAS IN THE BOSS
SAYING TO YOU IMPEACHMENT AND
TRUMP ARE THE BIGGEST STORY IN
AMERICAN POLITICS RIGHT NOW.
I AM WITH JESSE.
I DON'T SEE THAT THERE'S
ANYTHING NEWS IN THIS OR
EVIDENCE OF BIAS.
REPORTERS, DON'T LOSE SIGHT OF
THE BIG STORY BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THE AUDIENCE WANTS TO HEAR
ABOUT.
>> Greg: EMILY, THEY MAKE IT A
BIG STORY BY SAYING THAT.
WE HAVE TO KEEP IT GOING, KEEP
THE FLAME GOING.
>> Emily: THEY ARE CREATING
THEIR OWN FIRE.
WHAT STRUCK ME ABOUT THE TAPES
WAS WHEN THE GUY SAID THEY, THE
SEATED EXECUTIVES, THEY DON'T
LIKE TULSI GABBARD BECAUSE SHE
TAKES AN UNCONVENTIONAL ROUTE
WITH POLICY.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT COMES OUT OF
THE LEFT AND THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY WILL NEVER SUPPORT FREE
THINKING.
THAT WAS THE SADDEST PART, NOT
THAT THEY'RE FOCUSING ON TRUMP
AND IMPEACHMENT BUT THAT THEY
ARE IGNORING EVERYONE ELSE THAT
DESERVES ATTENTION.
THE FINAL POINT, IT KILLS ME,
MAY BE BECAUSE I TRAVEL SO MUCH,
323 MILLION PEOPLE ARE SUBJECTED
TO CNN IN AIRPORTS AND I
ENCOURAGE EVERY AIRPORT TO LET
THEIR CONTRACT LAMPS BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING TIRED OF IT.
>> Dana: YOU CAN'T BUY BOTTLED
WATER OR WATCH CNN AT THE
SAN FRANCISCO AIRPORT?